[Applaudissements]
comme il l'a dit je suis moi aussi un
petit campagnard
mais sur les côtes montagne du fouta
djallon qui s'est battue et qui n'a
presque jamais réussi à faire ce qu'il a
voulu il est toujours fait ce que le
destin a décidé pour lui un peu comme
ramadam un peu comme un t on à et ses
petits copains nous avions ce stage en
fait déjà à waldhambach je souhaitais
faire l'école nationale d'agriculture
ou sortir et d'ingénieurs c'était à
être nommé commandant d'arrondissement
donc c'était ça ma vision voix et
s'était pas beaucoup c'était au niveau
de la collectivité
rien à faire on a continué le pack
va voir
un bac mathématiques à la baie avec
mention peut mieux la guinée
et puis
je serai faire économie et finances
j'avais un cousin je viens il me dit oui
ici à conakry on arrive il dit bon il
faut faire comme une finale oblige aime
bien j'aimerais les orientations était
automatique en m'orientant j'ai omis
tout faire impossible de changer
les mines au moins c'est un vil petite
ville la géologie c'est la prose les
montagnes je vais fermin nos eaux
m'affecte en géologie
rien à faire je continue je sors je
soutiens avec mention excellent
au moins je vais servir
là aussi impossible
aux m'affecte enseignants à l'époque la
révolution tous les premiers étaient
automatiquement versée dans
l'enseignement je dis bon j'accepte là
je vais enseigner à la faculté des mines
de poke est impossible on m'a fait en
faculté d'agriculure à faranah
je fais si moi je refuse de rejoindre
ma tante vient me chercher ap ok je
rejoins faranah
j'exerce je vois que c'est est rude
j'avais perdu ma mère déjà six ans
mon père
un peu plus tard j'avais fini les études
j'avais deux soeurs qui ne comptait que
sur moi elles ont eu le bac qu'orientés
à conakry 6
rejoint difficile - inexistant c'était
le commerce de la révolution même un
maître de crémone il fallait un pont et
pour avoir un bon il fallait être connue
donc de faranah
j'avais deux petits rideaux que j'ai
arraché pour amener à mes soeurs à
conakry en guise de trades lit
alors je me suis dit que je pouvais pas
me contenter de ça je vais en vacances
mali par un enseignant je vais mali un
cultivateur des patrons qui a rendu
visite à mon père
mois de tous les métiers de
l'administration
il ya un que je ne souhaiterais pas pour
mes enfants c'est être enseignant il
savait pas qu'il avait un enseignant
devant lui
ça m'a choqué en plus des conditions
très difficiles de l'enseignant à
l'époque pourtant déclaré militants
d'honneur
alors qu'est ce que je fais après ma
soutenance je décide de me guider je
vais en côte d'ivoire avec ma thèse
je vois
la direction de la géologie je me
présente il dit je cherche un emploi
mais dix bornes messieurs laisser boire
votre thèse vos coordonnées dans trois
quatre mois ou venez nous voir
rentrer en guinée je reprends enseigne à
faranah
j'avais des copains comme cellou dalein
président de l'upg et d'autres en terre
farama avouent qu'ils me disent non ne
faut pas les faux pas aller mais
je réunis mes petits salaires
je fais le trafic de faranah kuendu en
sierra leone j'achète du tissus
vêtements créés pline chaussures pâte
dentifrice je viens à kindia la ville d
agrumes je revois mes produits j'achète
un sentier de manier greffer
que je transporte à mali je dis pas je
vais occuper mon père a surgi pendant
que moi je m'exile
verger et là mon père est décédé mais
c'était le premier manga préféré
malissol encore reproduise
finalement je suis pas parti en exil
parce que
quelques mois après le ministre m'a
piqué tu
m'appeler avec certains de mes parents
pour me dire qu'il a des problèmes la
faculté peau qu'elle veut changer le
doigt si ça m'intéressait je dis oui
c'est ainsi qu'on m'a nommé douanes
faculté géomines de bloquer une faculté
de second degré à l'âge de 28 ans et
j'étais venu
je venais de quitter cette faculté 5 en
avant mais prosser était là et imaginez
vous même la responsabilité que gérait
de venir diriger mes professeurs
en matière d'éducation d'étude de
conseil scientifique
d'orientation
je pense que c'est la plus grande et la
plus délicate mission de ma vie même pas
celle de premier ministre et donc
après cela
il ya eu
avril 84 changement de régime là encore
on me bouscule pour faire le doctorat
malgré moi j'étais habitué de réconfort
de la direction de la gestion
des que
le régime en charge est un dépresseur
tenait au poste lui a remis le poste on
m'a donné une bourse de 3 mois pour le
maroc c'était juste une bourse de
perfection mais grâce à dieu elle a été
transmis un bourses de doctorat de
troisième cycle
donc
je suis resté là trois ans
attendait les montagnes rota place le
haut sommet d'afrique
avec comme repas tomates sardines
oignons et ce dans la brousse voilà donc
cette étape et puis après je rentre au
pays
on met des enseignements que je dis là
ça s'est fini vraiment c'est fini alors
ma prix
du comité de suivi
la présidence la république c'était
jarre de conseil de l'inspection de
contrôler tout ça et
on a eu lieu là quelques années
et découvert certains mini ce dernier à
la salle le ministre ibrahima sylla
ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères
et il a conduit une mission en chine il
a négocié la construction du palais ses
retours et ce sont neuf
[Applaudissements]
et puis voilà tout s'est passé comme ça
et je vous raconte tout ça pour dire
comme ramadam comme idée dans la vie il
faut persévérer on ne fait pas ce qu'on
choisit ce qu'on veut mais
persévérer sur votre route et le
meilleur est à venir les jeux ce n'est
pas comme disait quelqu'un ici il n'ya
pas d'école de directeur de ministres ou
encore moins de premier ministre c'est
dans l'effort quotidien que que tout
cela arrive je pense que ce que nous
avons entendu ici c'est une grande
source d'inspiration pour tous les
jeunes qu'ils sachent que
ce qui est important c'est le combat
chacun d'entre nous doit se faire et
puis c'est ça l'essentiel être au
service de soi même d'abord de sa
famille
pour faire reculer la pauvreté parce que
c'est si chacun de nous est dans ce sens
que collectivement grâce à l'aide de la
puissance publique que nous allons
éradiquer complètement la pauvreté
avancé donc je pense que c'est un peu
comme ça bien sûr je vous raconte pas
tout ce qui s'est passé après
fonctions
[Musique]
de
ministre de premier ministre pour ça je
ne vous raconte pas juste
pour finir je vous dirai quand
j'étais premier ministre
tatis a dit j'étais presque président
sage l'assument le président conté était
malade et m'a donné tous les pauvres de
nommer deux juges de le représenter à
l'étranger tout le monde le sait ici il
décède et puis
j'étais la première victime arrêté pour
des tourments
celui qui avait tout les finances du
léman de la république entre ses mains
au caire reproche pour la primature
aucun des ministres
n'a été convaincu de détournement
c'était pour soi-disant des dossiers de
famine et
de 2005
étaient des choses mais dadis lui-même
avait expliqué que c'était des
accusations
normal c'était pas
subir tout ça mais c'était de savoir qu
en âme et conscience
vous n'êtes responsable de rien et que
toute l'opinion soit retourner contre
vous et que vous soyez amené à raser les
murs ou des choses que vous n'avez pas
commises c'est extrêmement important
comme quelqu'un qui dirait on vous
reprochera toujours quand vous faites
pour le pays ou quand vous parlez pour
le pays tout ce que vous avez fait et
tout ce que vous n'avez pas fait donc je
souhaite que la jeunesse prenne ses
responsabilités face du discernement
comme battait havas pour le meilleur de
nous même jour annexes
[Applaudissements]